[Music]
so
it's ellie are you serious this is dead
of testosterone you can't invite a girl
to a place like this well
i'm gonna buzz her in she's not gonna
talk about xbox i'm gonna be sitting
here being like i have to fart but maybe
i can't right now she better have some
hot friends
open the door i don't care i'm getting
wasted
is that ice cream yeah it's peanut
butter chocolate give me the airstrip no
i need it
my girl broke up with me what are you
bridgette jones do you ask him little
man give me ice cream
oh yes ice cream we're going out
if you're single we're staying single
with you man hey you guys want a mint
that's a weird mint dude it's cause it's
a boner pill you got four hours to drink
like keith richards still get funky
so you guys still haven't gotten mikey
any action like nothing
it's just harder than you think this is
the part where we go home because i'm
i'm not really you're sitting on my coat
hmm my girl's staring at you then in the
bar
what do i
i was going to make you wait like 40
days i was gonna make you wait too
then i realized i'm a dude
we're not supposed to see him more than
twice in one week and you're seeing this
chick twice in one day
what's the deal with you and chelsea yes
we'll see what are you doing here anyway
[Music]
what the what the it doesn't mean what
you think it means it doesn't oh what
does our relationship mean to you then
wait you guys are in a relationship
[Music]
i've been trying to pretend that things
haven't changed hey come here man
do not hug me with no pants right
respect
being there for someone when they need
you
that's all relationships are
[Music]
i love you i love the way we fit
together in bed because we're the same
height our crotches line up
really good i love that i love that yeah
man so why don't i tell her that
i'm doing it i'm doing it man you're
doing it
dude which one of you idiots used to
self-tanner i do
why because i thought it was lotion but
now my junk is orange oh no
that looks like a traffic cone it looks
like a sad giraffe
[Music]
you